Hey guys what's up Marvel dropped the best
bomb this morning new game in collaboration
with Square Enix.
So I'm going to explain what's going on they're
making a game that's going to tie all the
movies all the comics everything together
in a much more expansive version of the experience
you get when you go to MCU movies and it's
not just one game.
It's a series of games so is going to feature
some of the most iconic things from the comics
and the movies so because the game isn't out
and I can't give a copy of it away I'll say
new round of the Spider-Man giveaway starts
now it's for a copy of the new Spider-Man
game.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video be sure
to click that bell to enable alerts so you
don't miss anything.
This all might look a little familiar to you
because the same studio this working on that
this was like a collaboration it's the people
behind the tomb raider games up until very
recently Deus Ex.
So just based on the footage that we see in
this it looks a little bit like those types
of games but they tease that the avengers
need to reassemble and were heading into in
avengers year because of Avengers infinity
war.
So it sounds like this is going to be like
a big RPG style game they make it seem like
it's gonna be a linear RPG like a lot of those
other types of stories, but the way they tease,
it's going to be playable for a long time
either.
There's going to be a crap ton of DLC or they'll
just be a series of games said in this universe
with these characters.
So you'll be like one of the avengers trying
to reform the team in the wake of this giant
disaster talk about teasing the iconic moments
from the marble cinematic universe, even though
the story is supposed to be original.
So it sounds like they'll be taking all the
stuff from the movies and recontextualizing
a little bit and you get to play around in
the movies just a little bit more with those
types of adventures which I think people want.
It's almost like taking one of the big Avengers
films and turning it into a 50 hour event
which is what we want for infinity war.
I would totally watch of 50 hour infinity
war movie.
So marble just want you to be doing a lot
of avengers things going into in avengers
year but they also have the guardians of the
galaxy Telltale Games.
It's coming out we haven't seen any real footage
from that.
Just like the logo teaser in the fact that
there making it Marvel versus Capcom infinite.
They haven't officially announce what the
real title of the game is going to be or which
characters are going to be playable like which
person you're getting at the start of presumably
it'll feature all of Marvel's main characters
from the comics pending Spider-Man because
there's all the Sony Spider-Man game stuff
that's happening.
Spider-Man is a big?
So you guys can let me to what you think about
the idea of like a Deus Ex Square Enix tomb
raider style avengers game of you like everybody's
freaking out about this is the first big non-Spider-Man
AAA Marvel game in a while in the fact that
it's coming from Square Enix is just amazing,
but for those you wondering if it's gonna
be more like Final Fantasy or Deus Ex I'm
expecting it to be more like Deus Ex just
based on the look here, but they could go
any number of different directions with it.
There's no official release date announce,
but I'm guessing it's either going to be Christmas
shopping season this year or sometime early
next year.
Games usually get delayed a lot.
Lily more trailers for the there will is more
information as they go along.
They mention so much about the movies in the
TV shows in this announcement though.
So it just sounds like they're going to be
including all of the MCU stuff as well as
the TV stuff, so for those you that one a
story that involves both the movie characters
and the TV characters like infinity war no
people want them to go into the movies, it
sounds like this is the middle ground as far
as gameplay mechanics I'm expecting Deus Ex,
but like I said it'll be like a combination
of open world and linear RPG, just like tons
of side quests.
So here's a little bit more of this Deus Ex
gameplay footage just to give you an idea
what that might be like augmented arrow began
with such promise to the incidents turn the
world upside down 50 million hundreds of thousands
more on the Joseph you which opportunists
plotted in secret to control us today.
Hatred honks is more to do a full-blown mechanical
parts with violent clashes, fueling unrest
the augmented of suffering genocide begins
occasionally on right.
So you just have to imagine something that
looks and feels like that universe only done
with the scope and stories and characters
of the Marvel universe as well as the marble
cinematic universe on talk about the comics
to think of Marvel infinity classic infinity
gauntlet storyline everything that's happened
on earth so far, so with each new game.
It just sounds like the stories will get bigger
and crazier as we go along through phase 3
phase for the movies they talk about all the
environments all the places the of events
from the comics so you might get to see a
version of the infinity gauntlet happen you
might get to see stuff from Black Panther
from Thor Ragnarok just up from all corners
of the Marvel universe.
And I say universe in the grand sense of things
were talking space-based stuff Earth-based
stuff just to be clear Marvel in Square Enix's
partnership is for multiple games so either
it's gonna be a game series set based on this
new one right here or it's going to be a couple
different types of games, but it sounds more
like it's going to be a series like tomb raider
or Deus Ex or something like that.
So based on the development cycle that'll
probably go all the way through the fourth
avengers film and well into Marvel phase 4
see how Marvel tries to sort of like tie its
games and its extra properties into the MCU
stuff that's going on.
So the be a lot of MCU stuff happening in
the games but it'll be a lot of extra stuff
that you don't get from going to the actual
movies so will be much bigger world a much
bigger story like 50 hours of gameplay versus
two and half hours of movie was just really
good news.
This is the best announcement they could've
made it was in an actual MCU movie trailer
like I know everybody wants a Thor trailer
they want more Spider-Man will be plenty more
that, and there's actually some behind-the-scenes
Avengers infinity war.
Spider-Man that I want to post.
The just a lot of stuff that they been doing
lately because they started shooting the movie,
so they'll be another infinity war video sometime
on Friday but I have some new Star Wars I'm
going to post some new Thor Ragnarok, so those
will be the next videos that I post while
you guys wait for that to post you can click
here for more defenders behind-the-scenes
and you can click here to learn all about
Star Wars, thank you so much watching everybody
high five I'll see you guys in the next video!